And of course, once you've gone through the proof,
this was a rather easy quiz just for relaxation
after all of these Boolean formulas and satisfiabilities.
So of course, this formula has polynomial size,
because when you constructed it,
we took care of that.
It can encode any algorithm.
We did not make any special assumptions or restrictions on this algorithm here.
It can also encode any input, because that basically just means
whatever we're given, we encode it into memory and we know we can do that,
and finally, of course, that was the purpose of the construction,
this Boolean formula up here is only satisfiable
if solving this problem for this input returns a yes;
otherwise, if it's a no, you can not satisfy this formula.
And this of course is the whole purpose of the construction,
because what we have now shown is
that solving SAT on this Boolean formula
is the same as solving this problem
for this input here,
and what that means, of course also is
if you can solve SAT on this Boolean formula here
in polynomial time,
then you have a polynomial time simulation of this algorithm here
running on this input.